PRASHANT GULATI: Hello and
welcome to Event-Driven
Microservices with Cloud Run.
My name is Prashant Gulati.
So how do you know if you're
in the right session today?
You're in the
right session today
If you're looking to learn
more about working with events
for use cases and
video analysis,
file conversion, new user sign
up, application monitoring,
or hundreds of others,
if you're looking
to learn about how to act on
events originating from Cloud
Storage, BigQuery, or dozens
of other Google Cloud sources,
and if you're
looking to modernize
to event-driven architectures
and improve both developer
productivity and
your bottom line.
Let's get started.
I'm going to be covering
four topics today.
We'll start by describing
the rise of Microservices
and some of the problems
inherent in them.
We'll then move on to describe
event-driven architectures
and how they solve
some of those problems.
We'll introduce you to
Google Cloud's new offerings
in this space,
Events for Cloud Run,
and events for Cloud
Run for Anthos.
And we'll conclude by showing
you a Sentiment Analysis
demo, which takes
in a complex image
and performs Sentiment
Analysis on it.
Let's start by describing
the rise of microservices.
There are several architectural
styles in software.
Monoliths, for instance.
Perhaps, your organization
has monoliths.
We're going to take you on a
journey today from Monoliths
to microservices to
event-driven microservices.
Let's start with monoliths.
They're fairly
easy to understand.
As you can see on
the screen here,
here's an e-commerce store
with six component services.
There's a few problems that
are inherent in any monolith.
Scalability.
Component services scale as
a group and not individually.
Extensibility.
It's hard to add
or update services.
And lastly, coupling.
There are often coupled
dependencies between services
that you have to deal
with in a monolith.
So to address some
of these problems,
you might want to chart a
migration to microservices
by pulling out
component services
into separate services.
Let's take a look at
the example over here.
We've pulled out a couple
of component services--
the newsletter and the shop.
As we continue this migration
and pull out a third service,
you start to see the connections
between the services develop.
As we pull out a fourth service,
the connections between them
deepen further.
We've now completed the
migration to microservices.
While we've started to
address some of the issues
with scalability,
extensibility, and coupling,
we haven't done so completely.
We've improved on
scalability, but there's still
the question of whether the
communication between services
is synchronous or asynchronous.
That makes a difference.
We've improved on extensibility.
However, the new
services that we add
may still require
that we make updates
to existing services that
are going to communicate
with that new service.
And lastly, while we've
made coupling looser,
it's possible that
different services may still
have couple dependencies--
on a message cue,
for instance, which
you may want to take a
dependency on if you're
looking to protect against
intermittent failure
of services.
In addition to
the three problems
that we've only
solved partially,
microservices also introduce
three new problems.
For one, there's a spider web
of point-to-point integrations
like you saw in
the previous slide.
There is the potential for
expensive inter-service
communication, especially if the
communication between services
is pull-style,
saved via polling.
There's also the potential for
a non-uniform communication
format between services.
We continue our evolution onto
event-driven architectures.
But first, let's start by
describing, what is an event?
There's three concepts
to think about here--
occurrences,
events, and actions.
In the operation of
a software system,
an occurrence is when something
happens, a statement of fact
about something happening.
An event is a record
expressing that occurrence
and its context.
And an action will
take place based
on an occurrence, which is
communicated to a service
through an event.
Now, events originate
asynchronously.
And with events, a
producer has no expectation
of how the event might
be handled by a consumer.
Let's take a look at a typical
event-driven architecture,
or an EDA.
Multiple Event Producers
go ahead and produce events
and send them on to
Event Intermediaries.
At the other end,
Event Consumers
subscribe to the
events in particular
that they're interested in
from specific producers.
Now, EDAs solve
several of the problems
that we identified earlier.
Let's start by looking
at scalability.
Take a look at these two systems
that you see in front of you.
One can handle 200
transactions a second,
and the second can handle
100 transactions a second.
Now, with just a
microservices architecture
where the communication
between them is synchronous,
a request response
style, the weakest link
dictates the peak
throughput of the system.
But if you then graduate onto
event-driven microservices,
the weakest link now dictates
the sustained throughput
of the system.
Let's take a look
at extensibility
and how it's easier
to add services
with event-driven architectures.
We have a couple
of Event Producers
and a couple of Event Consumers.
We're going to go ahead and
add another Event Consumer.
When we add an Event
Consumer, no changes
need to be made to any producer,
thus making extensibility
a lot easier.
Let me highlight some
of the other benefits
of event-driven architectures.
We can now decouple from
dependencies completely.
The Event Intermediary
can handle
intermittent
unavailability of services.
There's no more spider web.
No more point-to-point
integrations.
Event Producers can just fire
events and forget about them.
Events are pushed, and this
replaces pull-based polling.
And lastly, there's
an opportunity
to introduce a standardized
format, a uniform communication
format between services.
For instance, Cloud
Events format.
With an ideal event-driven
architecture system,
users no longer
have to be experts
in distributed computing.
They can take event
ingestion, delivery, security,
authorization, observability,
and error handling for granted
and just focus on their
application code for their use
case.
This brings us to Google Cloud's
new offerings in this space.
You're already
familiar with some
of Google Cloud's offerings to
help you with microservices.
Cloud Run.
Cloud Run helps you run any
stateless container on Google's
fully managed infrastructure.
And there's Cloud
Run for Anthos,
which helps you on any stateless
container on Google Kubernetes
engine, is Knative
conformant, and helps
you achieve portability to
other clouds or on prem.
Today, we introduce to
you two new capabilities
to help you with
event-driven microservices,
Events for Cloud Run, and
Events for Cloud Run for Anthos.
Both these capabilities
help you easily build
event-driven architectures.
Let's take a look at both
of these capabilities one
after the other.
With Events for Cloud
Run, you can set up
triggers to act on events
sourced from all Google Cloud
sources via Cloud Audit Logs--
for instance, Cloud storage,
a popular Google Cloud Source,
via Cloud Audit Logs.
You can also act on events
from custom applications that
publish events to Cloud PubSub.
Events for Cloud Run
delivers these events
to Cloud Run targets.
Let's now talk about Events
for Cloud Run for Anthos.
Events for Cloud run
for Anthos is Knative
based and incorporates the
concepts of Knative brokers
and triggers.
With Events for
Cloud Run for Anthos,
you can act on events
sourced from all Google Cloud
sources via Cloud Audit
Logs, Cloud Storage and Cloud
Scheduler in particular,
which are native integrations,
custom applications that
are publishing events
to Cloud Pub/Sub, and
also custom events.
You can target Cloud Run for
Anthos targets, Kubernetes
services, and also any URL.
With both Events for
Cloud Run and events
for Cloud Run for Anthos, they
both handle event ingestion,
delivery, security,
authorization, observability,
and error handling for you.
They both have the same delivery
guarantees as Cloud Pub/Sub.
At least once
delivery, for example.
They both provide on demand
scalability and cost.
And you can operate both of
them through a UI, CLI, or API
interface.
Both Events for Cloud Run and
Events for Cloud Run for Anthos
deliver events in
CloudEvents format.
This also allows
you, the user, to use
CloudEvents available
SDKs in multiple languages
to be able to work
with your CloudEvents.
We also provide libraries to
help you unmarshal the event
data within CloudEvents.
I'd now like to take you through
a Sentiment Analysis demo,
showing you the use of
Events for Cloud Run
and Events for Cloud
Run for Anthos.
We're going to take
a complex image
and process it with an event
driven architecture system
that we're going to build.
For example, take a look at
this image here of a family.
Now, the holidays bring out
all kinds of different emotions
in different members
of the family.
What we're going to try to do
here is from an input image,
draw out each family
member and determine what
their sentiments are,
what their sentiment score
is, all using event-driven
architectures.
Now, to accomplish such an
event driven architecture,
there's a few microservices
that we're going to need.
A Cloud Storage Bucket,
a Firestore Database,
and a few different
compute services.
Now, these can be Cloud
Run services or Cloud Run
for Anthos services.
To start, we need
one service which
can help us extract the
bounding boxes of faces
from the original image.
We need another that
can extract face images
from those bounding boxes.
A third that can run those faces
through an open neural network
exchange model, and
then generate an emotion
score from them.
A fourth that can write those
scores to a Firestore database.
And a fifth to render
a user interface.
Now, let's take a
look at how we can
stitch these
services together in
an event-driven architecture.
Let's go back to
this diagram, which
you're familiar with from
earlier in the presentation.
We have Event Producers
and Event Consumers,
with an Event Intermediary
in the middle.
Let's now bring in some
of the microservices
we need for our specific demo.
Here, you see the Cloud Storage
Bucket, the Firestore Database,
and the five compute
services that we identified.
As a reminder, these
can be Cloud Run,
Cloud Run for Anthos, or
a combination of the two.
As we start to put
this service together,
let's walk through the flow and
start to stitch it together.
A user uploads an image
to a Cloud Storage Bucket.
This should then fire an event
to an Event Intermediary.
That event is then sent to
the first compute service.
The first compute service
then sends a custom event
published to Pub/Sub back
to the Event Intermediary.
This, then, reaches
the second service.
The second service
extracts face images
and places them
in a Cloud Storage
Bucket, which then
fires another event back
to the Event Intermediary.
This then moves on
to the third service,
which runs those faces through
the open neural network
exchange model and generates
the emotion scores.
An event is then sent to
the Event Intermediary
once again, which then reaches
the fourth compute service.
The fourth compute
service writes a score
to the Firestore
Database, which then
fires another event to
the Event Intermediary
and updates the user interface.
I'm now going to show you a
demo in which we've already
put together several of the
components of the architecture
I described, but it's
missing one trigger.
So we're going to
wire up that trigger,
and then we're going to also
show you the entire system
in operation.
We're now going to head to
the user interface of one
of our Cloud Run services.
This is the second
Cloud Run service,
and we need to add
a trigger to it
to allow it to receive events
from the first Cloud Run
service.
To do this, we're going to
head to the trigger step.
We're going to start by
clicking on Add Trigger.
We're asked to specify
a trigger name.
We're going to leave the
default suggested value as is.
We'll head to Event
Type, where we're
going to pick Cloud Pub/Sub.
This allows us to receive events
published as specific Cloud
Pub/Sub topics.
We're asked to select
a Cloud Pub/Sub topic,
and I'm going to select one that
I'd already created earlier.
As I click on Save, this will
complete trigger creation
and complete the setup of our
event driven architecture.
I am now ready to head
over to our cloud storage
bucket, to which
I'm going to add
the original image of the family
that we showed you earlier.
Once again, here's the
image of the family.
I'm going to take this and drag
this into the Cloud Storage
Bucket.
Now that we've added this image
to the Cloud Storage Bucket,
it's going to kick
off a series of events
as we described in
the setup earlier.
If all is well and working
well, when I move over
to the next tab which
represents the fifth Cloud Run
service for the
user interface, we
should see images for
each of the family
members along with
their sentiment scores.
So let's go take a look.
Here we are.
You see images of each
of the family members,
the two parents on the
right, and the two children
on the left.
The parents have higher
happiness scores.
Right after their
happiness scores,
that have neutrality scores.
And the two children,
as you can see
from their facial expressions,
have higher neutrality scores
followed by sadness scores.
So what did we
just see right now?
We created an event-driven,
rapid autoscaling
scale-to-zero service.
We created an event
trigger, and we
triggered CloudEvents to be
sent to Cloud Run services.
There's a few key takeaways
I'd like you to take away
from today's presentation.
You as a user can transform
your company's IT systems
to enable real time business
so your customers and business
users can get what they
want when they want it.
And in doing so, this enables
a layer of high value services
that really make a
difference to the bottom line
of your business.
I invite you to
try both offerings
we've discussed today.
Events for Cloud Run
is in Private Preview,
and you can sign up by
going to bit.ly/events-cr.
Events for Cloud Run for Anthos
is also in Private Preview,
and you can access it
bit.ly/events-cr-anthos.
Both offerings are
coming to Public Preview
by the end of
September of this year,
and we invite you
to join us when
they come to Public Preview.
Once again, my name
is Prashant Gulati.
My email address is my first
name, last name, at Google.com.
I would love to hear from
you comments, questions
and feedback.
Thank you very much.
I hope you enjoy
the rest of Next.